love the game success for me is the
process love the making
what's that believe nation it's Evan I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so today let's learn one
of the most popular rules that
successful people follow love the
process also if you want to know what
Gary Vee Casey Neistat Terry Crews and
others have to say about building
unstoppable confidence check out my 250
for confidence series where every day
for the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence the link is in the
description below
the reason people aren't patient is they
value other people's opinions too much
skill I use a probably communication
which I think you're building on what
Garrett said I think communication is -
a two-way street
whatever you're thinking about it you
will not get it until you take action
[Music]
what are the qualities that you think
made for a true and a successful
entrepreneur what's important she or he
has to love the game for me a purebred
entrepreneur she or he loves the journey
mm-hmm not the stuff you know one of the
things I struggle with in the current
state of entrepreneurship is a lot of
people want the vacations the watches
you know even even the context is this
you guys have such an incredible imagery
I think it's remarkable
who doesn't want fine things in life
yeah but I think that if you're in the
game just for the fine things in life
for the bottles and the models and the
private planes I think you're gonna lose
and it definitely is not my definition
of an entrepreneur my definition of an
entrepreneur is somebody who can't live
without doing their thing and trying to
create literally suffocated success for
me is the process and I've realized that
every time in life where I've sort of
reached a been a benchmark that's
enabled me to pause when I pause the
misery yeah I hate it I hate it when I
sold my HBO series and I had two years
before it aired I was miserable -
exactly and I don't like that so I think
that like it the journey the process is
the reward for me so like right now
starting something new this is the most
successful time in my life and whatever
this yields like when that exit or
however it might manifest takes place
like sure that's great and it's a cool
story but it doesn't equal happiness all
right like beam the most exciting part
of starting a tech company was you know
when it was my my Matt Hackett my
co-founder and I just the two of us
sitting in a room trying to figure out
that to me was like the pinnacle of
success you know when I was at MIT it
was like sitting in that lab every
single day across from these brilliant
minds that was the that was success for
me so the journey is what I strive for
and it's what excites me the most and
with three six eight it's like it's
really building to enable that journey
as much as possible I'm not focused at
all on a finish line
there is no let's raise 100 million
dollars of venture money and existing a
unicorn I could give it like this I mean
I feel like the finish line is like
every day for you like
every day restarts and it's there's no
real yeah I mean the the journey is the
reward the work is the reward the
passion came from the love for the game
you know I loved everything about it
like the smell of the ball you love the
smell of the ball yes the ball you know
the smell of like brand-new sneakers and
like the sound the ball makes when it
hits the ground sneakers in the gym yeah
the ball going through the net like all
those things I love and so the passion
comes from that because once you have
that love you just want to be a part of
this thing all the time
is there one moment where you can say it
defined your passion for basketball is
their story or moment when you said yeah
that wasn't it that was it that was like
when I felt really passionate no it
doesn't never leave never leaves like
you know the game was just a part of me
so it never leaves even now that I'm
retired you know everything I've learned
from the game of basketball carried it
over into life you know like basketballs
helped me be a better person a better
friend but how solid well because
there's life lessons that are within the
game like communications like
unselfishness my attention to detail and
empathy and compassion like all those
things are in the game and as an athlete
if we are aware of those things it helps
us become better human human beings
mm-hmm and you can apply that toward
your post post basketball days
retirement into your business world
surely true ventures sure I mean you can
plan you know I was applying that even
when I was playing just in life outside
of the game and even more so now you
know I'm building a business and all
these things you know kind of culture
you when I have and all those things are
or directly learn from the game of
basketball to me this is one of my
favorite messages and if I had to give
advice to somebody to have success in
any field not just entrepreneurship in
any field you look at the people have
the most success in any field they enjoy
the process and too many people are
attached just to the outcome if you want
to make a blockbuster hit if you want to
make a successful movie you have to
enjoy the process
of making movies as an entrepreneur if
you want to have a successful product
you want to have a great service that's
make a lot of money you want to have a
huge business whatever you define is
huge or successful then you need to
enjoy the process of the work that
you're doing on a day to day basis and
not everything is gonna be amazing
you're gonna have down days but net-net
you have to enjoy what you're doing you
have to wake up and look forward to the
day that is ahead and too many
entrepreneurs are spending 80 to 90% of
their time doing stuff that they're not
good at that they don't want to be good
at that they hate because they feel they
need to do it to grow their business and
only 10 to 20 percent of their time on
the stuff that they can be genius-level
act and you will not have success in any
endeavor if you're only spending 10 to
20 percent of your time or less on the
stuff that you have the potential to be
the best in the world that and that you
enjoy if your goal is just to make a lot
of money and you'll do whatever it takes
just to make that amount of money you'll
never get there because you don't enjoy
the work where the secret to success is
enjoying the day-to-day grind because it
doesn't feel like a grind it feels
enjoyable the actual making of a film
the day-to-day go into work the
construction of them there's always been
my favorite thing I like making it feel
much more than I like watching them I do
and even the ones I'm in I really love
the coming together with a whole bunch
of people having an idea on paper and
everyone's got everyone's an expert at
what they do and you're and you're off
on this journey you've got ideas but
then you just let him let it let it go
and see what it can become
I love the making that's when I'm
happiest is when I'm making a film or
telling the story at the day to day and
more so than watching him really the I
mean look I kind of define that for
myself about four years ago process
probably stay in process head down in
process stay in your bubble and when
it's over be that fulfillment notice
when I started noticing that fulfillment
of it I just finished well that's enough
that's it I don't know if this thing I
don't know if it's even coming out
I don't even know if I don't know what
it's gonna turn in man I hope they I
hope we got it and I hope the director
put something good together
but I don't know nothing I can do about
that all I know is this experience that
I said go have the experience Makani and
if I can love this experience and at the
end of it I'm like may never even hear
that film again may never know that
story again it may be gone let me find
out that all the negatives cut fried the
x-ray machine there is no film but I've
gotta be that's okay I had an experience
when I got selfish for that for that
experience when I got that process
enjoying that process the day to day
architecture of making a movie and
creating a role that's that's what I've
been the happiest and more results have
come that way in an odd way you know but
I did you saw when I started really
approached them as this is a finite
thing and this is just that experience
other than that I'm not producing this
thing I'm not the one editing thing I
don't know what it's gonna be
that's it and then all of a sudden they
come out and you go oh I think who's got
a good one
you've made ginormous announced money
what do you guys plan on doing the rest
your life you've achieved so much
already I think you know there are many
important things to life you know aside
from financial or career success and in
fact it's not necessarily the ultimate
success that motivates you it's the
process of getting there and the
technologies or products that you build
or in whatever realms you may be and so
I'm not too concerned about finding
something to do though I do think it'll
be based on doing things that I really
enjoy and not have some end goal in mind
Danny very early on when I got Kostas
thought that brought me onto the set of
on then
you know tracksuit pants and t-shirts
for seeing Danny there and them Ironman
costume and knowing that Avengers was
coming up and just thinking how am I
gonna pull four off and how the hell am
I gonna stand ups of this guy and under
this you know but he he um he was - you
know his cry he gave me some great
advice about what an opportunity that we
were all involved in it wasn't directed
you know at me was himself he was
talking the group you know a new Captain
America was coming Thor Iron Man and he
said you know we're part of something
special and it's just you know it's
gonna be a hell lot of fun and um and
that that's it you know I think you got
a got to enjoy the process you know it's
um if you focus too much unsaid about
what's the result of it all do you know
you're not right in the middle of it you
know in the it's a giant cliche I've
been in the moment of it all you know
and the economy that was a nice gonna
remind rather than try to kind of keep
that with everything I'll do this just
as an actor you don't control the
spectrum we asked the directors
producers and stuff you know if you
cathedra sure you come out and do you
think that on film you know ten
different takes and you know across
however many days you know that sixty
days or whatever there's there's forty
or fifty different versions of Thor you
know that Kenneth Branagh cut together
in the first film you know like and
whether you liked it or not that you
know that was that was a version that
was put together by a lot of other
people you know and and that was
something kind of satisfy or attacks
that the white off in in thinking you
know what I actually can't control this
no matter how much I think I can or I
try to there's some comfort in kind of
letting go with it especially walking
onto a set like this with ensemble like
that it's like good-looking freaking
share this way yeah and although the
finger gets pointed at individuals
whether director writer actor whatever
the team effort no work or file I like
making things I'm a guy who should have
a project I I mean II when I was a chef
I was clearly somebody who liked
multitasking but I think I like making
things whether it's a TV show
a story
a plate of food I don't really even need
to have it afterwards the the the
process I think being a chef cooking
conditions you to the tiny technical
satisfactions of properly executing a
single plate having a kind of a private
moment when that plate sits there
momentarily in the in the window before
it goes out it in the dining room to be
ruined
where you look at it and you know you
did is you did this particular thing
well it's a very private moment I think
that's been useful in being learning to
like something so temporary so fleeting
I think that's been a useful in in being
happy and television and and and writing
I you know I like the process of the
editing process the pre-production
process that the nuts and bolts that
they get the technical satisfaction of
putting these pieces and elements
together in conjunction with other
people and having a one tiny golden
moment where you say that's pretty good
I am technically out of work at the
moment and I mean then that's something
that you that you just see you swimmin
you know you're very I'm very used to
that and that to me is it
Muse's me that one is nominated for an
Oscar and I'm out you know but I don't
go and wait a table can I you know it
would not it not right now I'm enjoying
it though I think you've got to you have
to embrace it and surrender to it and
not and enjoy I think you have to
remember to enjoy it this is where
trainers mess people up I've had
trainers who totally just want to prove
that you could never
do what they do and they have you pain
just to say light though and they go to
blast you like they want you unless
you're in pain and you feel like you're
sick and you're throwing up yeah that's
a workout no yeah you look at you yeah
you are you hurt you can walk great yeah
and the whole point is what I tell
people is treat the gym like a spa the
first time you ever go just go in there
and walk around touch the weights get a
drink of water walk around and then
leave and and I mean literally do that
for like a week two weeks until you just
get to the habit of getting in that door
because what's gonna happen is
eventually you gotta start lifting
because you're there yeah and you're
gonna do something and then you stop
don't ever get to the point where you're
like I can't it doesn't work I've been
working people want they say they want
my body and all this stuff but I've been
working out consistently since I was 14
years old and I'm 44 I'm 33 years of
hard core to our workout thirty years
yeah
so it doesn't happen overnight you just
have to enjoy the process
total learn to enjoy it cuz I'm sure
there was a point where you started to
enjoy using a hundred thirty pound yep
and that's the only way you're gonna
keep going now I've got a really special
bonus clip from samuel l.jackson on how
to love what you do that I think you're
gonna really enjoy but before that it's
time for the three-point landing
questions time to move from just
watching another video to taking action
in your business or in your life and if
you're brave leave your replies in the
comments below here we go question
number one what are the five most common
ways that you help people number two how
many of them do you enjoy the process of
not just the result of helping and
number three which can you replace with
something that you enjoy
listen there's so much that you don't
know about what will happen to you if
you become an actor or you become famous
that you know all this shit's gravy you
know that's what it is but you're still
doing the work I mean this is nice yeah
it's about the work it's not about all
the other the others a byproduct of it
now you can buy into the others and and
lose yourself in it
and lose yourself in the bush people
tell you about yourself and about you
know the kind of you do you know
everything I do is not great yeah good
but it ain't great I do good work and
some movies I know that that's happened
I know what they are they know what they
are but people watch them anyway because
there's something about them that made
me want to do it mm-hmm I enjoyed myself
doing it and it just didn't work out
well but if you buy into all this or you
start bullshitting yourself about what
all this is then you can get up in it I
read everything people write about me
hmm
cuz I'm that kind of guy I remember a
lot of people that say bad [ __ ] about me
because I'm that kind of guy I remediate
I remember the people who write good
about me because I'm that kind of guy
we're in this business because it's a
look at me from business and if you say
you don't do that you're a liar you lied
yourself you're lying to the people who
watch you even those moves that go but
so far scream well why don't we pay 1250
to watch your ass if you're not gonna
you know if you if you can't watch it I
damn sure don't want to watch it I watch
my movies I want to see myself when I
was onstage
I always wanted to see the play I was in
with me in it this is the perfect venue
for that hmm I watch my movies some of
my watch over and over again if I'm
Chancellor from the nothing else is on
it I pass the movie I'm in I'm in I'm
not watching it because that's what it
is
it's a look at me business and I got
into it because I enjoyed the fantasy of
it I love make-believe I love movies I
love entertaining people that's what we
do raise your standard Apple at the pool
it's core value is that we believe that
people your passion can change the way
people not one drop of my self-worth
depends on your it's supposed to man if
you guys liked this video check out the
one I made on the top 10 lessons for
life career and money the link is right
there next to me I think you're gonna
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there fail big that's right fail
big